Where do the historians get what what
what century did Jesus live in?
>> First century.
>> Where do you get that from?
>> Other external s like secondary sources.
>> What are what are the primary sources
that they use to say that Jesus lived in
the first century?
>> Just testimonies. Testimonies of people.
>> Yeah. What testimonies? I know. I know.
What testimonies? What what are the
primary testimonies that they use to put
Jesus in the first century and that he
spoke Aramaic and Hebrew?
>> Could be Josephus, other historians.
>> Wait, I said primary, not secondary.
They're tertiary. What are the primary
sources that they use? Cuz Josephus is
not the primary source they use. What's
the primary source they use?
>> Primary sources? I don't know. Maybe
just the Bible.
>> Oh, beautiful. So, the historians that
you're relying on are using the Bible,
the New Testament, to give you accurate
historical information about Jesus. You
just cut yourself, bro.
>> It's [music]
[singing]
how's it going?
>> Oh, God.
How you doing, man?
>> What it do? What it do? Pretty good.
Pretty good. How are you?
>> Yes. How did how did Allahh make you
believe in the crucifixion?
>> He made it appear that Jesus was
crucified.
>> And who did he make it appear to?
>> To whoever was there.
>> Okay. So, you're doing like an internal
critique, right? So, you're allowing
that Allahh did actually present to the
people that Jesus was crucified. But the
specific people that we're referring to
are the deceivers that were trying to
kill Jesus. So we're talking
specifically here, the Jews. So the Jews
that were trying to kill Jesus were
deceived into thinking that Jesus was
being crucified when in reality he
wasn't.
>> Were they the only ones? Were they the
only ones who believed that Jesus was
crucified?
>> No, just let me finish. So okay,
>> the knowledge that was the knowledge
that was transmitted through those Jews
>> were then taken,
>> right? So it's the fault is on the
people who took the false testimony of
those Jews who are already deceivers and
evildoers.
>> [clears throat]
>> Uh so did did the believers of Jesus
also believe in the crucifixion?
>> No,
>> they didn't they didn't think that he
was crucified.
>> So if so when you talk about believers
here, there's there's going to be like
two categories. There' be like the first
category that would take like the Jews's
uh testimony which wouldn't be justified
and there would be the other people who
didn't take their testimony which yeah,
of course that would be the right thing
to do. So, who are the people who were
going around saying that Jesus was
crucified and that they saw him rise
from the dead? Who are they?
>> Not rise from the dead. But if we're
talking specifically crucifixion here,
it
>> you don't you don't believe that anyone
was going around in the first century
saying that they saw a risen Christ.
>> Yeah. So, there were people claiming
that, but this is like a complete red
herring to the point of uh Allah making
you believe in the crucifixion. Well,
>> it's not. It's actually right on the
point. Who are these people?
It'll be the early Christians. However,
the early Christians claim there's a
resurrection is a distinct point to them
claiming that there was a crucifixion.
Well, doesn't comment on the the Quran
doesn't comment on the origination of
the resurrection. It comments on the
origination of the crucifixion.
>> Well, why why do they believe that Jesus
was risen from the dead? How do how do
they think that he died? These early
Christians,
>> they assume that he was resurrected from
the dead for many reasons. One reason
would be that he's a man that was
crucified and was elevated in status and
was risen.
>> Got it.
>> So, so with so so with these these like
sort of points
>> believing that a pious man had died and
was risen
>> meaning risen to heaven, there would
have been like these doctrines that
would have
>> no not not risen to heaven. Risen from
the dead. They believe he was
resurrected from the dead.
>> Yeah. I don't I don't I don't I don't
believe Allah has anything to do with
like
>> I I I understand that. But they believe
that he was risen from the dead because
they believe that he died in the first
place, right?
>> Yeah, but that's a nonsequity. It
doesn't necessarily entail that he's
resurrected because he died.
>> Oh yeah, you're missing the point. They
believed that they saw a resurrected
Christ. Not saying that it's necessarily
true. Just we're talking about what they
were saying. They claim that they saw a
resurrected Christ when resurrected from
the dead. So they believed that Jesus
died by crucifixion. Correct?
Yeah. So, so let me let me let me give
you like what our perspective would be.
It would be that the Jews would have saw
that Jesus was crucified. They would
transmit that that story or these like
um these sayings that he was crucified.
>> Then people would have developed a
doctrine. Obviously, it wouldn't mean
these Jews. Christians would have
developed a doctrine of him resurrecting
as well.
>> Where does this where does it where does
it where are you getting this from that
the Jews uh would have given the
information to the believers of Jesus
that they uh that they cru that he was
crucified
>> because because the talks about how the
Jews specifically were the ones that
were deceived by Allah. So where does it
say that the Jews are the ones who
relayed the information to the believers
of Jesus and therefore they believed he
died and then saw a risen Christ later?
>> Because the only the only people that
has precedence within the Quran and that
actually saw Jesus being crucified was
the Jews.
>> That's not true. Where does it say that
they're the only ones who saw him being
crucified?
>> Yeah. So if you So Allahh deceived the
deceivers, right? So they planned and
Allah planned and Allah is the best of
planners in the context of showing them
something that was untrue. Correct.
>> Okay. But where does it say that the
Christians or the people who believed in
Jesus did not see or was not there at
this event that they would have gotten
all of this information from these lying
Jews. Where does the Quran say that or
taps says that?
>> Okay. So Allahh says that he deceived
the deceivers. Correct.
>> Yeah. And that's in the context of him
showing that Jesus was being crucified.
Correct?
>> Mhm.
>> And who are the deceivers here? They're
the Jews. Correct?
>> So if it's the Jews that are being
deceived by Allah and they are the
deceivers, why would it be including the
Christians?
>> Because it's not it's not exclusive to
them. It's not exclusive to them.
>> Because if you have because what you
have here, let me let me respond to you
fully if I can, please.
>> Yeah. what you what you what you have
what you have by your own admission is
that the believers of Jesus thought that
he was crucified but now what you're
saying is is that but where they got
this from was these Jews who were
spreading this information around where
do you get that from
>> it's from the taps
>> where okay where did the taps say the
the followers of Jesus believed that
Jesus died by crucifixion because the
Jews told
>> yeah sure
um just give me a I can pull up the tips
soon.
>> Okay.
>> But yeah, so I'm I'm going to need to be
off the app for a sec.
>> No worries.
In the meantime, guys, make sure you
guys are hitting the like button.
Welcome back.
>> Yeah. So, um, if you want, maybe you can
show your viewers as well. Just pull up
Quran 47
>> and pull up the onuran.com.
>> Which Which
Ib.
>> All right. [sighs]
Iben Cathir.
Oops.
And then underneath the section.
[snorts]
>> Yes. So the section that starts off with
and those who differ just read from
there.
All right. All right. [sighs]
under the section those who differ.
Yes. So while you're pulling it up, I'll
I'll just explain. So you got to show a
justification on why the Christians are
the ones who were also deceived or they
gained their knowledge from watching the
crucifixion happen. From the Quran, I
gave you justification on why it was the
Jews specifically and how the Jews
relayed that knowledge to these ignorant
Christians who believed. The Christians
who weren't ignorant and that didn't you
know obviously take the knowledge from
these deviant and ignorant and uh you
know evil Jews. These would have been
the true believers that would have been
on the huck. They would have been on the
truth.
Sorry, I tried to listen, but I'm not
that great at multitasking with the kill
crucified. All right,
>> and those who differ.
>> All right, so
uh and those who differ found it right
here. Hold on, let me make it bigger for
shoot all
>> YouTube.
What just happened?
Oh, my bad, y'all.
All right, over here. Let's go to make
it larger.
But they killed him not. Those who
differ follow nothing but conjecture.
Referring to the Jews who claim to kill
Issa and the ignorant Christians who
believed them. Indeed, they are all in
confusion, misguidance, and
bewilderment. This is why Allah said,
"For surely they killed him not."
Meaning they are not sure that Issa was
the one whom they killed. rather they
are in doubt and confusion over this
matter. So it says that the Jews and the
Christians are in doubt over the matter
if Jesus was actually killed
>> it.
>> Yeah. So the Jews who claimed it and
those ignorant Christians who believed
those Jews Yeah. I showed you
justification.
>> Well, wait justification. Wait one
second. I showed you justification for
my position. Can you justify your
position that you're trying to impose?
>> Well, hold on. Hold on a second. Hold on
a second. You quoting I doesn't help
you. Where does Itheir get this from?
That Christians heard the lies of Jews
and therefore believed them.
You just you just quoting you you
quoting somebody that shares your
position doesn't solidify your position.
>> Oh, of course it does because would have
would have taken of of course who's Ib
right? He's one of the most prominent
that we have and his is one of the most
prominent works that we have. So when we
talk about executing the Quran, our
definitive sources of information to
execute the Quran would be the Quran and
the Sunnah from
that's that's that's fine and all, but
this isn't this isn't just a hold on
just just really quick. Hold on. Just
really quick, Dean. Dean, you're making
a historical claim, Dean. This isn't
just this isn't just Quran and oh, I got
to stick to Quran. This is a historical
claim. So when I asked you, I asked you
just plain. I didn't ask based on the
Quran. I asked you, did the followers of
Jesus believe he was crucified? And you
gave the answer. They believed it
because the Jews told them the Jews who
were deceived told them and therefore
that's what they believe. This wasn't
just simply based on Quran. You're
giving me an historical answer. So this
is why I'm asking when when you say,
"Oh, you're just quoting Ibath that
gives this position. Where does he get
this from?" Just because says it doesn't
mean it's historically accurate.
>> Okay. So, so you're shifting the
goalpost now to what's historically
accurate and what's not historically
accurate to the point before that you
were making that Allah is the one who's
made you believe in the crucifixion.
Now, if you're if you're granting me
that Allah
>> how how long does there come after the
first century? Let me finish. No,
>> just really quick. How long does how
long does there come after the first
century? No. How how long how long does
there come after the first century?
Sure.
Um, again, you ask me a different
question. Can
>> Yeah. Just this this should be easy. How
long does I get there come after the
first century? It should be easy.
>> Yeah. A thousand plus years.
>> A thousand plus. So, a thousand plus
years later, you're relying on a guy a
thousand plus years later that says that
the first century Christians believe
that Jesus was crucified because the
Jews who were deceived told them. What
is his basis for this?
>> No worries. Okay. You allow me to
finish.
>> Go ahead.
>> Okay. So, the point is is that Kafir is
giving giving us an ex Jesus of the
Quran for Muslims, right? So, Muslims
are going to hold to the presupposition
that whatever is the definitive source
of information that we can rely upon is
going to supersede any non-definitive
sources of information coming from
history. So history comes through words
of mouth through fallible human beings
so on and so forth. We have the Quran
and the Sunnah coming from the prophet a
definitive source of information for us
and Allah's words another definitive
source of information for us and that's
what he's basing his opinion on. He's
not bas basing his opinion on some
fallible work or some fallible
historical documents or some fallible
historical relaying of a message.
>> That's what that's what it that's what
it sounds like to me.
>> I interrupt you again interrupt I didn't
interrupt you. Well, let me finish. How
long you going to go? Is this a
monologue or are we talking here?
>> I didn't I didn't say you were having a
monologue when I let you finish
>> cuz I didn't I didn't talk for longer
than 2 minutes.
>> Let's have a conversation, bro. You
don't got to You don't You don't need
>> Yeah, it has hasn't even been a minute.
Like,
>> let's let's have a Dean. Dean, don't
please don't do Please don't do none of
this crying stuff, bro. Let's engage
with each other. You just made a claim.
You just made gave your reason.
>> Let's go ahead and make Let's go ahead
and engage. Let's not do this, man.
Could we engage, please?
Yeah. So,
>> okay. So, let's let me engage with you.
You don't you don't even need to repeat
what you said. I heard what you said.
So, now you said that you said that is
is relying on um basic is relying on the
Quran and Sunna. That's what you said in
a in a in a in a just is that correct?
>> Yeah. Those are the only two definitive
sources of information.
>> Beautiful. Those are the those are the
sources of information that I is pulling
from. Where from? Where? Okay, since
he's using the Quran and the Sunna,
where in the Quran and the Sunna does it
say that the that the Christians
believed the Jews that Jesus was
crucified? Where does the where does the
Quran and the Sunna say this?
>> That that the Jews specifically believed
that Jesus was crucified.
>> No, I'll ask it again. Where? Because
Ibicad says, and this is your position,
that the Christians believed Jesus was
crucified because the deceived Jews
relayed that information to them.
>> Okay.
>> And so they deferred on this. My
question is, and you said he pulls this
from the Quran and Sunna. Where in the
Quran, where in the Sunna does it say
that the Christians believe Jesus was
crucified and it's because of the it's
because of the Jews? Uh what they said?
>> Yeah. No worries. So the point I'm
making isn't that every every opinion
from Quranic exedites are going to be
exactly found in the Quran and Sunnahb's
[laughter]
opinion is based upon the Quran and man
where we have if if his opinion is
compatible with the Quran and Sunnah we
take from it your view that you wait
pause there pause there no wait pause
that that's beautiful that's beautiful
what you said pause there pause there
yeah everyone sees this pause there you
you said, Dean, that their that what
they say that their opinions Dean, hold
on, Dean, cuz you're you're you're stuck
here.
>> You just said that their opinions their
opinions are compatible with the Quran
and the Sunna. So now, so now it's not
it's not simply just because at first
you said they were he's getting it from
the Quran and the Sunna. Now it's oh
well, you know, it's compatible with the
Quran and the Sunna. You see how you
switched there? So, show me where in the
Quran and the Sunna it's compatible.
Where does it match?
>> No words. No worries. Instead of just
letting me say one sentence and taking
my words out of context,
>> you said multiple sentences and when you
said something, that's where I stopped
you.
>> Give me one minute. Just can you give me
one minute to speak?
>> One minute. You need one minute to
answer the question.
>> You You've been rambling for two
minutes.
>> I've been rambling. Give me one minute.
>> I've been rambling. [laughter]
[snorts]
>> So, can you give me one minute?
>> I like you a lot, Dean. I do. I like you
a lot. Sir, can you give me a minute to
reply?
>> I I'll give you enough time. I'll give
you enough time.
>> Okay. [clears throat] Okay. So, when I
said he takes from two definitive
sources of information, what I was
referring to is that those are his
standards by which he will interpret the
uh any text within Islam based upon
other texts within the Quran and the
Sunnah. Now your position that you're
trying to you know advocate for within
the Quran and Sunnah isn't compatible
because Allah says at the very beginning
I told you he deceived the deceivers.
The Christians aren't the deceivers. So
they're not part of that category. How
did the Christians have this knowledge?
Through the transmission of the
deceivers. That is compatible with the
Quran and Sunnah. That's why I don't
have a problem with the interpretation.
The same way I don't have a problem with
him using the substitute theory. It's
not in the Quran and Sunnah but it
doesn't matter. It's compatible with
him. It's it's a valid tape.
>> Got it. So So now guys, where we're at
here is that um it doesn't have to be in
the Quran or the Sunna. Uh but I can
make something up. Um and it could line
up somehow with uh the Quran's position
and therefore you can take his
interpretation. That's this is Islam,
ladies and gentlemen. This is Islam. So
thank you Dean for I mean I I mean I
don't know I don't know how where do we
go from here. Uh we we have a position
where there just makes stuff up.
>> It's not in the Quran. It's not in the
Sunna. Even though you said he gets his
stuff from the Quran and the Sunna. We
when I asked you okay show me where in
the Quran and the Sunna that he got it
from that Christians believe the the
Christian uh that the the Jews who were
deceived. That's not in the Quran and
the Sunna. Uh but it's you know it's
compatible with it. You know, it he's
inter his interpretation doesn't go
against what the Quran says necessarily.
It could be it could be compatible. So,
he could just make stuff up and then you
can go with the interpretation. It's a
pick me religion, bro. What What we
doing here, man? What we doing here?
>> Okay. So, so the point the point would
be that we have two definitive sources
information.
>> You don't have you don't have a Wait,
wait, stop. Stop there. I'm sorry. I
don't mean to I'm sorry that I'm cutting
off. I'm sorry that I'm I'm start I'm
sorry and and I apologize for cutting
you off here,
>> but you don't. You just said that you
have two definitive sources of
information when you're not definitive
on nothing. You're not definitive on
nothing. I just asked you where in your
two definitive sources does it say this
and it's nowhere to be found. You had to
go to Ibikir where I you said is pulling
from these sources where this stuff is
nowhere to be found. What are you
talking about? If it's definitive, show
me from the Quran and the Sunna where it
says anything that you and I are saying.
>> Are you done?
>> I'm waiting for that answer. Show me
that your sources are definitive in this
matter. Show me where definitively it
says what you're saying it says.
>> Okay. The point is that we have these
two definitive sources that are
repeating yourself. You're not even
going to answer the question
>> to be our standards to be our standards
by which we will interpret the Quran. So
when we interpret the Quran, we have
only a set boundary because of the
limitations Allah has set within the
Quran and Sunnah. Within that boundary,
Can you let me finish?
>> You're just you're saying you're just
saying stuff. What is that what is that
boundary?
>> You spoke for a good two minutes. I
didn't say you're having a
>> What is that boundary?
>> What does that boundary?
>> Can you let me finish?
>> What is what does that boundary do?
yourself. Honestly,
>> I No, you're embarrassing yourself.
You're saying your sources are
definitive without showing any
definitive answers. You're embarrassing
yourself.
>> You're not letting me finish.
>> This This is This is why I'm I'm happy
that I'm happy that you're here.
>> By the way, guys, this is one of their
This is one of their smart guys
supposedly.
>> Go ahead.
>> Can you let me finish?
>> Okay.
>> You have no answer.
>> We have two We have two definitive
sources of information by which there
are both standards where we interpret
the Quran and Sunnah from within these
boundaries of the Quran and Sunnah. We
can have differences of opinion. One set
of opinion that you brought up that I
told you to justify is in contradiction
with the Quran when it says Allahh
deceive the deceivers. The Christians,
the believers aren't people that are
deceivers. Who are the deceivers in this
context? It's the Jews. So because it
because the Jews are the ones who are
being deceived by Allah. Allah has
nothing to do with anything that comes
afterwards. Allah only has to do with
those who have been deceived who are the
Jews. And of course in the Bible like I
don't know if you want to get into
discussion if whether God can deceive or
not. We can get into that but I think I
think we should move on from this point.
>> Okay. Think I know you would want to
move on from this point. This is why I
cut you off because you say a lot of
nothing and I try to get you to hone in
on the important points instead of the
waffling. You didn't say anything in
this entire time that you spoke. So I'll
ask you this again since you got two
definitive sources. Where in your
definitive sources does it say that the
Christians thought Jesus was crucified?
Where does the Quran say this? Does it
say it? Just a quick answer, please.
>> Sorry, repeat your question.
>> Does the Quran say that the that the
Christians believe Jesus was crucified?
>> It doesn't comment on that.
>> Okay, it doesn't comment on that. So,
according to two definitive sources,
guys, these sources are definitive, by
the way, but the Quran doesn't comment
on that. Here's my second question. Who
are the ones explicitly from the Quran
uh who thought Jesus was crucified?
>> The Jews. Okay. So, if anyone says that
the that the Christians thought that
Jesus was also crucified, does that
contradict what the Quran says?
>> Oh, my days. You don't know what a
contradiction is? You know what a P not
P is?
>> Oh, what what what about what about
non-compatibility? What about
non-compatibility? Cuz you cuz you said
Yeah. Let's let me let me switch. Let me
let me let me switch it. Hold on, Dean.
Dean, cuz you're trying you're trying to
run away, Dean. Dean, you're trying to
run away. Let's let's let's let's take
away Let me use your words. You said
compatibility. You said compatibility.
You said compatibility.
>> Is it compatible if if the Quran
explicitly says that it's the it's the
Jews who are the ones who thought that
Jesus was crucified? Uh is it compatible
to say that the Christians thought that
Jesus was crucified?
>> No, it's I'll tell Okay, you're going to
have to let me finish.
>> It's just a quick answer. No, cuz it's
just a quick answer, please.
>> Okay. So, I give you oneworded responses
and you monologue. Is that right? No,
no. It's just a quick because I'm I'm
making a point here. This is why I'm
asking the question.
>> I'm building the blocks here.
>> Okay. Repeat your question. Go ahead.
>> So, so since the Quran, as you admitted,
only explicitly says that the Jews are
the ones who thought Jesus was
crucified.
>> Yep.
>> Is it compatible to say that Christians
also thought that Jesus was crucified?
>> Yes. Yes, it is.
>> All right. Beautiful. So, now guys,
watch the here. Watch here. He said that
my view of me saying that as a Christian
uh as a Christian I am incompatible with
the Quran's view that Jesus was
crucified tricked by all because Allah
made it appear so. Um even though it
doesn't say that he made it appear to
the to the Christians also. Right? It
the Christians also. But I'm I'm
inferring that that because Allah made
it appear to people that I also the
Christians that that means that I am
contradicting and not compatible with
the Quran's narrative. Even though the
Quran because the Quran doesn't say that
it explicitly says that there was a
particular people who uh were deceived
into thinking Jesus was crucified
specific people just like here it says
that there was a specific people who
thought Jesus was crucified doesn't
mention the Christians.
So, if we're going to be consistent,
Dean, if you're going to be consistent,
I'm not incompatible with the Quran's
view, even though it doesn't explicitly
say that also there were Christians who
were also deceived by Allah when he made
it appear that Jesus was crucified on
the cross. Even though it doesn't
explicitly mention them, I'm not out of
line if it's not out of line to say that
Jew that Christians believe Jesus was
crucified because Jews taught them that.
Because Jews Jews are the ones who
spread that message. Don't be you got to
be consistent.
Okay, I'll let you like ask you a set of
questions. I gave you direct responses
and I let you monologue for a good two
minutes. Can can you let me speak?
>> It's on you, bro. [snorts]
>> Okay, thank you. So, yeah. What is
compatible is that you asked me can the
Christians believe is it compatible with
the
>> Okay, can you already interrupted me?
>> Well, you you you started you started
off misrepresenting my question.
>> Let me Can you let me speak? Can you let
me speak? And then once I'm done
speaking and I ask,
>> well, can you get my question right?
>> Okay, repeat your question. Go ahead.
>> Wait, wait. See, see, now you want me to
talk when you So, I I was I was only
trying I wasn't even going to like inter
I was just interjecting like, hey,
that's not what I asked.
>> Okay, repeat your question. Okay, my
bad. My bad. I have a bad memory. Repeat
your question.
>> So, my my question my first question
was, did the Christians believe that
Jesus was crucified?
>> That was my first question. Is that is
that what you're talking about?
>> No. No. You asked if it's compatible.
>> Okay. Okay. Yeah. So yeah, that's what I
asked you, right? Was it um uh is it
compatible to uh to say that the
Christians that the Christians believe
that Jesus was crucified with the in the
Quran? You said yes.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Even though it doesn't explicitly say.
>> Let me add context here. Okay. Add
context.
>> So yes, only in the case if you're
saying that they believed he was
crucified through the transmission from
the Jews. if they believed he was
crucified by witnessing a deception. No,
that's not compatible with the Quran.
That's what you were trying to say
before. So when you said that Allah made
me believe the crucifixion, no. Allah
made the Jews believe in the
crucifixion, not you. Okay. So do you
see what you're doing there? You're
doing it again. And it sounds like you
kind you completely missed the point
that I made. Notice how again you're
saying that the reason why I am
incompatible with the Quran and saying
that the that the Christians also
experienced the deception is because the
Quran explicitly mentions a particular
people who experienced the deception.
Right? That's your point, right?
>> Yes. The deceivers are the Christians
deceiver.
>> Okay. No, it's stop because but but hold
on though. Hold on. Okay. So when it
says that specifically a particular
people were the ones who were deceived
into believing a a crucifixion
um and therefore if I say anything
outside of what was explicitly stated, I
am not compatible with what the Quran is
saying, then you cannot say that the
Christians believed he was crucified at
all because the Quran only mentions a
specific people, the Jews, the who were
boasting about his crucifixion that
believed that Jesus was crucified. So to
say that Christians believe he was
crucified is going out is is going
against what the Quran says is not
compatible according to your own
standard of compatibility.
>> Okay. Okay. Let me let me make it simple
for you. There's two levels to this. The
first level is Allah deceived the Jews.
If you pull up what we just read before
to help you understand, there's the
first level which is the Jews who were
deceived by Allah. Then if you hold that
those who were deceived by Allah
includes the Jews, this is completely
uncompatible and this has all that has
to do with what Allah did. Then there's
a second level to this which is the
Christians who had the information
relayed to them by the Jews of what they
witnessed. Okay? And this is what Allah
says. He implies this ambiguously saying
that all they talk all they have to base
this is conjecture. What is the
conjecture here? It's the Jews spreading
the rumors of what they saw. Y the Jews
who spread these rumors, they're they're
reprobate Jews. Jews who tried to kill
Jesus. You're not justified in taking
their testimony. So this has nothing to
do with Allah.
>> Dude, that makes absolutely no sense. If
you're saying that there's two levels
now, now now remember Oh, wait. Hold on.
I didn't cut you off, did I?
>> Go ahead.
>> So now we're switching from your
definitive sources. Now the the the
commentary of Ibikir is now your
definitive source. Not the Quran and
Sunna. Now it's Ibikir because your
Quran is it doesn't say anything on
this. I'm going with your standard bro.
So now when you say now you had to go
with Ibadir's commentary who he where
where he's adding where the Quran nor
the Sunna speak on. Matter of fact the
where the he's going against where the
Quran and the Sunna are explicit on. You
now have to try to assume. Wait wait
wait wait wait a second. Let me finish.
>> Please tell me how he's going.
>> Let me let me finish. Let me finish.
Man,
let me
>> let me man. Come on, man.
>> So, when you're when you're over here,
[laughter]
you So, the part where it says, right,
um, but but, uh, those who differ among
this, they they they just follow
conjecture. Now, you're in, you're
saying this implies that Christians are
involved in this. No, it doesn't.
Christians aren't are nowhere even
mentioned in the context. All of this is
about Jews and the Jews who are
boasting. All of that. That's all it's
about. So the only those who are dis who
are who are uh disagreeing in the matter
would have to be the Jews. Man has
nothing to do with the Christians. So
again, you are incompatible. You and I
wish he was here because I cook him too.
Both of you guys are incompatible with
the Quran according to your standard of
what compatibility is because the Quran
is speaking explicitly about a
particular people and you and I are
going outside of what the Quran
explicitly talks about just like you're
saying I'm doing. So therefore, we're
both incompatible with the Quran. H or I
can do exactly what you guys are doing
and saying the Christians also
experienced a um a deception who were
there witnessing the crucifixion at the
cross.
So either we're both incompatible or we
can both do this and talk about what the
Quran doesn't explicitly say.
>> Okay. Okay. Two two points two points I
want to I want to address. The first
point is you're conflating
incompatibility with external sources.
Just because something's an external
source doesn't mean it's incompatible is
an external source from the Quran and
Sunnah. Sure, he's doing his own. He's
doing his own interpretations based upon
what he already has knowledge on within
the Quran and Sunnah. So, he has these
boundaries to work upon. Now, just
because he's an external source doesn't
mean he's incompatible. Your
interpretation is incompatible with
Allahh's deception, including the
Christians, because the Christians
aren't part of those who are being
deceivers. It's [laughter] only the
truth. Those those who are in a
disagreement that can't be talking about
the Jews. This is so like like this is
such poor exesis on their part because
if they're in disagreement, why would
they be in disagreement of something
they just witnessed? This is obviously
talking about the Christians disagreeing
hearing the testimony of the Jews and
then also and then also other Christians
believing that Jesus wasn't crucified.
Okay. Now, why would the Christians be
those who are in a disagreement? Sorry,
the Jews. Well, how would the Jews be
the ones who are in disagreement if they
just witness with their own eyes Jesus
being crucified? That makes no sense.
>> Um, [clears throat] so dude, I haven't
conflated anything. I have only used
your lit literally your own standard.
I've only used your own standard. You
have been saying I'm not saying that
because there's an outside source that
makes him incompatible. You're saying
you said to me that because my
interpretation or what I said is not
explicitly is not involved in what is
explicitly mentioned in the Quran about
who it's referring to that therefore I
am now out of I am not compatible with
the what the Quran is saying. So I'm
just holding you to the same standard
that you're applying to me.
>> Sorry. Repeat that. I liked her a bit.
>> I said that I'm only holding you to the
same standard that you're applying to
me.
>> I didn't say that because Ibath is an
outside source that therefore he's uh
you know incompatible. I'm going with
your standard of incompatibility that if
what is if I'm saying something that the
Quran did not say but not just what the
Quran didn't say but when the Quran
explicitly is talking about something in
particular or people in particular if I
add in other groups other peoples or
other another something to to what the
Quran explicitly talked about then I am
not compatible with what the Quran is
saying that's what you said That's
wrong.
>> You said that's wrong. That's what
that's been your entire position. What
are you talking about?
>> No, no, no. Okay, God lo put it very
simply for you.
>> Within my position that I just relayed
to you, can the Christians be part of
those who are deceived?
>> Yes.
>> Yes or no?
>> Yep.
>> No, no, they can't.
>> Why not? They were at the Why not? They
were at the cross. They witnessed it.
Yes. Absolutely.
>> I My position I relate to you. Did I say
they are the ones who witnessed it?
>> Uh Not necessarily. Not not not your
position, but my position is that they
were there. They witnessed it.
>> Okay. I'm I'm Okay, brother. I told you
my position. Okay. I made very clear. I
said my position. So, I'm going to I'm
going to ask you one more time.
>> Were they there?
>> Within my within within my because I
want to know if I don't think you're
actually understanding what I'm saying.
So, within the crucifixion, we have the
Jews who were trying to get Jesus
crucified
>> and they were deceived into thinking
that Jesus was on the cross, but it
wasn't actually Jesus. Okay. So we have
this. Anyone that says that the
Christians were part of those who were
deceived are wrong because the
Christians aren't those who were trying
to kill Jesus. These were the Jews who
were trying to kill Jesus. That's the
first part.
>> I don't mean to cut you off. Stop. Can
you can you please pause there on that
first part, please?
>> Let me just let me just let me let me
finish. I can make it clear. The second
part of the verse is those who are in
disagreement. Those those who are in
disagreement are the Christians. Okay?
That that is compatible. If you're going
to say,
>> "Brother, do you think the Jews are
those in the disagreement? Those who
just witnessed Jesus get crucified. What
are you talking about?
>> Okay. Now, now let's go with your first
part. Let's let's go with your first
part. Were there Christians who
witnessed the crucifixion?
>> No.
>> No. And what is your basis on that?
>> The Quran. The Quran says the deceivers
were deceived. The Christians fled. They
>> All right. So, no look look at this,
dude. You're saying that there were no
Christians, no no people who believed in
Jesus that were witnesses of the
crucifixion as when when history
completely dis disagrees with you. Um,
you have so but you're of course
>> of course but you're using Ibiker who's
trying to make a historical claim. But
you don't care about history. I know
you're anti when you're Islam. You're
you're ahistorical.
>> Why would I care about but notice this?
But notice this. According to your
Quran, who was it that thought Jesus was
crucified?
>> It was the Jews.
>> The Jews.
>> So then, thank you. Let me let me No,
no. Thank Thank you. Thank you.
>> You have you have to let me clarify.
>> You you already did.
>> I witnessed and also and also the
Christians who took their testimony.
>> Okay. Where does the Quran say that?
>> The Quran doesn't have to say that.
>> Thank the Quran doesn't have to say. So
the Quran doesn't have to say that the
Christians also receive were were there
to witness the deception of Allah. The
Quran doesn't have to say that. I can
infer that from the information of of
the event itself and all that we know
about the crucifixion event. I can infer
that just like you're inferring that
Christians were the ones who got
deceived by the Jews who were there when
the Quran doesn't say that. The Quran
doesn't have to. I can do the same
thing, bro.
>> No. No. Because your interpretation
contradicts what it's saying. mine
>> and so does yours. [laughter]
>> No, he doesn't. Show me the context.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Okay. Wait one second. One second.
I'll
>> We're in circles here, man. We're We're
in circles here. We're in circles.
>> Wait. Go. And also, one more thing. One
more thing. I want to clarify. When I
said I I I don't care about history as
well. I don't care about your history
that you derive from the Bible with no
first century manuscripts. Do you have
any first century manuscript?
>> What language did Jesus speak? What
language did did Jesus speak?
>> He spoke more uh there's difference of
opinion. I don't know.
>> Yeah. What what language is he? What
what language did he speak?
>> Some will say some will say Aramaic and
Greek.
>> From where? Where? Where did they get it
from?
>> Yeah, it depends on the person you ask.
You ask the Christian.
>> Where? No, no, no. I'm asking you, Dean.
What language did Jesus speak? Dean,
>> historians would say Aramaic, some
beautiful as good. Where did the
historians get it from that Jesus spoke
Aramaic
or Greek or Hebrew, whatever?
Yeah, just the context he lived in,
archaeological evidence.
>> Nice. The the context the the the
context that he lived in. How do they
put Jesus in any context that he lived
in where he would have been speaking
Aramaic? What what source do they use?
What's their source?
>> It could be archaeology or other
>> What archaeology? What What archaeology?
Come on, man.
>> I don't know. I'm not a historian, bro.
What do you want to say?
>> What What do you mean you're not a
historian, Dean? You know this. You know
this stuff. Where did the historians get
it? Le let's do this. Where do the
historians get what what what century
did Jesus live in?
>> First century.
>> Okay. Where do you get that from?
>> Other external s like secondary sources
and
>> what are what are the primary sources
that they use to say that Jesus lived in
the first century?
>> Just testimonies. Testimonies of people.
>> Yeah. What testimonies? I know. I know.
What testimonies? What what are the
primary testimonies that they use to put
Jesus in the first century and that he
spoke Aramaic and Hebrew?
>> It could be Josephus, other historians.
>> Wait, I said primary, not secondary.
They're tertiary. Whatever primary
sources that they use because Josephus
is not the primary source they use.
What's the primary source they use?
>> Prim primary sources? I don't know.
Maybe just the Bible.
>> Oh, beautiful. So, the historians that
you're relying on are using the Bible,
the New Testament, to give you accurate
historical information about Jesus. You
just cut yourself, bro. Thanks for
coming, man.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Do you
believe that? Thanks for Thanks for
coming, man. You just showed me that you
rely on the Bible that you just said you
do not care about historians.
>> That's historians. That's not That's not
my style.
>> That is you. Cuz you relying on the
historians. I asked you, Dean. I said,
Dean, what language did Jesus speak?
Dean, what century did Jesus live in?
You said according to historians uh uh
Aramaic and Hebrew and he lived in the
first century. You didn't even say
according to historians in first. You
you just answered it first century. You
answered that and you got that from
historians who used the New Testament as
you admitted.
>> Okay. Okay. The the New Testament. Wait,
wait one second. No,
>> no. De I got I got to move on, bro. I
I'll let you on again like
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. So, you want to you
want to make a point and and move on? I
I'll I'll be I'll be live Monday again,
bro. You can come back on. We got to
have another conversation.
>> All right, bro.
>> All right. Take care of yourself, man.
Thanks for coming up. [snorts]
>> All right. Thanks for showing everyone
you you don't know what to contradict.
>> And thanks for showing everybody that
you contradict your own self. [laughter]
My goodness.
I love this man. And guys, by the way,
he's one of their da guys. He's one of
their da guys. He's one of the supposed
smart ones. He's one of the ones who can
refute everybody. He's one of their
guys.
He's one of their guys. And it's no
different.